récemment j'étais à l'inauguration du
site
agora à koumassi pas le président macron
j'étais accompagné de confrères nous
étions six et j'étais la 6e et la seule
femme donc cinq ans et nous nous tenons
au milieu de la cour d'en attendre que
l'événement commence et en demi siècle
ce qui est en train de discuter et une
autorité particulière que nos solutions
rencontrer nous a été introduite donc le
monsieur il arrive il serre la main aux
cinq hommes
et puis quand il a fini sur les cinq
hommes il engage la discussion
donc ça m'a pris 10 secondes
parce que je me suis dit il va venir à
un moment donné me parler mais la
conversation avait des gens avaient déjà
commencé tout le monde est là un moment
donné j'ai pris l'initiative de mettre
le pied au milieu du demi siècle
et puis de dire bonjour donc là il se
tourne il se rend compte que je suis là
à bonjour madame et je le regarde je lui
dis en général on commence par les dames
et là il se trouve
[Applaudissements]
et là il se confond en excuses il est
bien embarrassé iru j en ferai tout ce
qu'il faut et puis un confrère à côté
qui se rend compte de la catastrophe
mais trop de vies qui dit manon karamoko
président directeur général d'unilever
côte d'ivoire est là l'autorité se
retourne et me salue à nouveau comme si
la maintenant il accepte ma présence et
ça c'est quelque chose qui arrive tout
le temps dans mon cas particulier
mesdames et messieurs aujourd'hui je
vous parlais de la préhistoire de manon
karamoko je viens d'une famille une
grande famille avec cinq grands frères
un petit frère et deux soeurs
je viens en huitième position imaginez
vous venir en huitième position avec des
grands frères qui sont deux fortes têtes
qui sont grands d'ailleurs et qui
parlent fort j'avais trouvé ma petite
solution c'était d'être excellentes à
l'école donc c'était un petit jeu comme
ça entre mon père et moi c'est que il me
demandait de lui ramener certains
résultats
et moi je les ramener et j'obtenais des
cadeaux et comme je voulais toujours
plus bon j'ai poussé un peu plus à
chaque fois et donc à partir de là pour
lui je suis un petit talent donc en
huitième position tient quand même on se
souvient de moi au milieu là on peut se
perdre mais la huitième l'an s'en
souvient et donc il pour lui je devais
être médecin à l'époque effectivement
c'était le top du top donc je tenais des
paracétamols à la maison quand les gens
vendent mal à la tête et j'étais
persuadé que c'était bon et donc j'ai
été bon en matière scientifique ça
allait jusqu'en première où mes notes
dans les matières scientifiques
s'écroule complètement est donc là je me
suis dit j'ai deux choix soit je passe
en terminale littéraire ou alors je
reprends ma première ce que j'ai fait
c'est d'aller en terminale littéraire et
j'ai promis à mon père que j'allais
avoir mon bac avec la mention et je les
fais
à ce moment là mon père une image qui
lisait beaucoup le magazine jeune
afrique et regardait les profils de
carrière et d'autres études de
nombreuses personnes y compris tidiane
thiam en particulier c'est de me dis il
faut qu'un jour tu passes le magazine
jeune afrique que je puisse le regarder
donc c'est quelque chose qui m'a driver
pendant tout le parcours
donc puisque je peux plus être médecin
faut que je trouve quelque chose
d'intéressant je commence à prendre des
cours de finance par en france on met
cours des finances et a priori je suis
plutôt bonnes en finance donc je
continue sur la finance ensuite j'ai
peur à boston je finis à un bachelor en
comptabilité ensuite g20 à washington
j'ai fait un master en comptabilité et
en finance
et puis je rentre en côte d'ivoire quand
je rentre en côte d'ivoire je commence à
travailler chez microsoft afrique de
l'ouest et du centre
quand j'arrive chez microsoft parmi les
cadres je suis la seule femme mais bon
j'ai l'habitude j'ai conduit au milieu
des garçons donc tout se passe très bien
et je me souviens de cette fois alors
nous sommes allés en réunion stratégique
au sénégal et quand on finissait les
cessions les hommes le soir aller
prendre un verre découvrir les beautés
du sénégal avaient leur petite escapade
est moindre naturellement j'avais je
restais soit en chambre où j'allais
passer du temps avec ma soeur qui vivait
au sénégal et les lendemains de ses
escapades edc soirée bien animée auxquel
je ne participais pas je me on avait des
cessions ou en général il était déjà
d'accord si certains points et je
n'étais pas là où il avait pris les
accords donc très souvent je me
retrouvais un porno position je me
débattais jean batailleur pour faire
imposer mes points de temps en temps ça
marchait pas ton temps mais une fois en
particulier j'ai éclaté en sanglots
parce que mon point était tellement
logique et évident pour moi et eux ils
s'étaient par dix aurait pris un
raccourci et que j'éclate en sanglots
ils ont
mon prise en pitié ok d'accord va lui
céder elle en train de pleurer ça va et
j'ai été encore plus frustré parce que
mon point ni là c'était de faire passer
un message
en aucun moment j'espérais obtenir leur
voix leur aval avec mes lames et je
pense que ces jours là je me suis promis
de ne plus jamais laisser éclater mes
émotions dans le monde du travail
je vais jouer à la maison je peux plus
longtemps que je veux mais pas au bureau
quand j'ai quitté microsoft
je rejoins le groupe novartis et chez
sandoz je rencontre cette dame
une dame fantastique qui a été ma bosse
pendant longtemps et qui a acquis
aujourd'hui qui a été mon mentor et que
je continue d'appeler quelquefois quand
j'ai des doutes elle m'a inspiré elle
m'a appris à travailler
elle m'a appris à être compétente à ne
mettre que sur le plan du travail en
fait tout ce qui est compétent ses
performances donc je vais je travaille
avec elle je vous laisse inspirer je
pense qu'il est important pour les
femmes d'avoir des modèles femme pour
comprendre que c'est possible et j'ai eu
un moment donné je suis enceinte
chose normale pour toutes les femmes et
j'ai part en congé de maternité et deux
semaines après j'ai ma petite fille
quand j'ai ma petite fille quelques
semaines après deux trois semaines je
pars faire ma présentation budgétaire à
dubaï
des gens se sont demandés si j'étais un
peu déréglé à ce moment là mais non en
fait ça a été une décision en plein à ma
conscience je c'est involontaire
ça n'a pas du tout été imposée par mon
employeur c'est parce que à ce moment là
je sais que on a besoin de moi on a
besoin du financier pour faire la
présentation budgétaire
je suis en congé de maternité 7 en fait
mais je vais bien prendre une semaine
pour aller faire ma présentation
budgétaire et revenir
et quand je reviens dans le feu de
l'action les choses allons très
rapidement
je reprends même pas mes congés de
maternité parce que dieu merci ma mère
est là et qui me supportent par derrière
je reprends le boulot et je prends un
congé de maternité ce qui m'a buzz
paraissait beaucoup plus intéressant
puisque j'avais le support à la maison
par petits bouts gelé koala des congés
pendant deux trois semaines en accord
avec mon employeur
c'était normal et là je me suis je suis
identifié comme talent dans l'entreprise
donc je pars à des formations un peu
partout et pendant que je suis en
formation j'ai fait mon réseautage
parce qu'il est important de réseauter
si on ne résoud pas ça veut dire qu'on
n'a pas un plan de carrière face à
troicki
en faisant le networking je partage mes
ambitions mon background un peu de ce
que je veux faire ce que j'ai déjà
accompli et quand je rentre au sénégal
quelques semaines après un voyage à
l'autriche j'ai un directeur financier
qui m'appelle oui maintenant comment
vas-tu je vais très bien tu te souviens
pendant la discussion qui m'a dit que
tout allait passer maintenant si fo qui
est directeur financier puisque jusque
là j'étais responsable financier je dis
oui il me dit bon écoute j'ai une
opportunité pour toi donc moi je
commence à sauter et de partout je lui
ai dit ce paillage et passe à la
prochaine étape
et puis me dit tu me demandes pas ouf
jeudi à 12h tu as is je me dis là il ya
un piège donc immédiat c'est toi je
m'assois mehmedi de pinasses et je dis
oui dit il me demande toujours pas jeudi
jude monde sait où il me dit alors c'est
pour couvrir une afrique l'afrique
anglophone est basé à lagos au nigeria
10 secondes vite
j'avais déjà dit oui donc je réfléchis
mais dit tu es là j'ai dit oui je suis
là il dit bon alors je lui ai dit écoute
je le prends il me dit mais tu ne veux
pas discuter avec ta famille d'abord et
tout ça je dis je te dis je le prends et
puis je vais les convaincre
[Applaudissements]
et après ça je dois suivre les
entretiens je passais pas des entretiens
naturellement puisqu'il ya plusieurs
candidats et le premier timing
d'entretien je ne peux pas le faire
parce que je suis en voyage je prends
l'avion et donc il reportait pour deux
jours après à 14 heures
malheureusement pour moi ce jour à 14
heures je n'ai pas de nous donc j'ai ma
fille de 2 ans qui a décidé que ce jour
là elle va faire l'entretien avec moi
donc à 11 heures gilles a fait manger
et puis je fais tout ce que je peux je
mets de continuer tout ce que je peux
pour essayer de la faire dormir non et
baby est cela devient chanteuse tout ce
qu'on peut imaginer et un moment donné
je me dis pompe
je la poche lamento je prends un pagne
j'attache bien et puis je commence à
marcher comme ça en me disant bon un
moment donné ça va passer on en afrique
ça marche ce genre de choses
non pas avec la nuit 13h50
elle encore dont elle encore présenté
dans mon dos l'entretien c'est à 14h
qu'est ce que je fais c'est à devait
être un vidéo call
je pose un ordinateur sur ma coiffeuse
et puis je me dis comment est-ce que tu
va gérer ça il faut que tu viennes
créative et j'ai la petite et appels
vidéo je coupe la vidéo et je garde
l'audio et la dame me dit mais j'essaie
de faire une vidéo mais ça n'a pas l'air
de construire vite ici si ça fonctionne
ça fonctionne très bien
je suis juste pas en position de pouvoir
faire un entretien vidéo ce moment et je
suis debout je suis là je joue mais
désormais elle va s'endormir que
j'aurais pas longtemps au lit et pis
c'est beau et puis mais je lui explique
la situation
on passe l'entretien et puis à la fin me
dis je vais quand même voir ça donne
quoi
donc je mets la vidéo elle me voyais je
suis encore en train de de bouger pour
essayer d'endormir la petite qui est
déjà en train de partir des sons de
romain froment et là elle me regarde et
me dit si j'avais des doutes sont à
résilience pour ce pour aller vivre à
les gosses au nigeria là ils se sont
totalement dissipé je pense que tu as le
pouce
et donc concours de circonstances aussi
toute heureuse
j'annonce à mes parents je me dis que je
suis folle et que qui valent au nigeria
en 2014 il ya beaucoup haram qui est au
summum de ces catastrophes et bouna
vient de rentrer se retient de façon
brève et puis une jeune femme
francophone avec une petite fille de
deux ans et nous nous dans un pays qui
est reconnu pour ses problèmes
sécuritaires et avec un monde qui est
très très machiste et bien moi j'y vais
je prends ma nounou ma fille et mes
valises on part au nigeria on passe de
super année au nigeria où je me dis avec
des personnes je pense pour la vie
aujourd'hui
et à la fin de mon séjour au nigeria
dans les discussions avec mon boss il me
dit quelque chose il nous dit manon
pendant tout le temps qu'on a travaillé
ensemble à aucun moment j'ai
l'impression de travailler avec une
femme
et là je le regarde je lui ai dit c'est
une injure
comment est ce que je dois prendre la
chose donc il le voit un peu sur mon
visage
et puis il ya 90 et très féminine rien à
voir avec ce côté là c'est juste que en
fait à aucun moment j'ai senti j'ai eu
l'impression d'avoir un problème avec
les femmes des émotions quoi que ce soit
j'ai juste eu quelqu'un de professionnel
en face de moi c'est quelque chose qu'il
avait énormément apprécié et je pense
que c'est le complément qui m'a le plus
ravi de toute ma carrière après novartis
au nigeria je rentre en côte d'ivoire je
travaille encore un an chez novartis
suis toujours le talent dont tout le
monde vient à moi et puis je me voient
proposer le rôle de directeur financier
chez unilever côte d'ivoire et à ce
moment là tout le monde me dit encore
que je suis folle je pense que je vois
docteur karaboué à la fin donc je me dis
c'est une entreprise qu'un difficulté
qui va faire mais qui fonctionne plus du
tout je dis bon je vais essayer j'aime
bien les challenges et puis je m'ennuie
un peu chez novartis veut faire quelque
chose de nouveau
donc j'arrive ce n'est le verbe en
janvier 2000
2018 avec tout mon courage encore une
fois et je me mets à travailler à
batailler avec tout le monde à secouer
tout a essayé de transformer les choses
transformer le monde
je suis très rêveuse et les équipes
regardent au début se dit celle-là va se
casser la gueule au bout de trois mois
et va partir et au bout de trois mois
effectivement je veux voir mon père je
pense que j'ai fait un mauvais choix de
carrière et finalement non au bout de
onze mois me propose l'intérim de la
direction générale en plus de la
direction financière
je me dis qu'est ce que je leur ai fait
c'est une punition et après je me disais
nouvelle expérience c'est une
opportunité pourquoi pas le pire qui
puisse arriver c'est que tu sois
directeur financier qui n'a absolument
rien à perdre donc je prouve site est ce
c'est trois mois trois mois pendant
lesquels j'allais avoir le support du
président du afrique bel 20 donc j'y
vais et pendant les trois mois je
travaille avec tout le monde je secoue
tout le monde je suis un peu comme ça
comme un taureau et puis au bout de
trois mois montre aussi bien il me dit
aman on écoute ça a l'air de plutôt bien
se passer tu as commencé à voir les
innovations qui commencent à sortir
c'est fascinant écoute ce qu'on va faire
c'est qu'on va prendre le temps de
chercher un directeur général et puis
enfin il tombe de trois mois là je
comprends la maison jeudi 28 c'est sûr
que là c'est une volonté manifeste
contre moi et puis après je veux type et
a déjà commencé vas-y pour la chose et
je continue je continue j'engage tous le
monde avec moi et puis au bout d'un an
de faire un relais de rôle du directeur
financier directeur général je suis
confiné au rôle de président directeur
général d'unilever côte d'ivoire
[Applaudissements]
donc la bataille chez unilever a
commencé à 38 ans et s'est amené en
oeuvre donc on m'appelle la plus jeune
pdg de côte d'ivoire
pour moi être une femme être une femme
ce n'est pas une raison ce n'est
vraiment pas une raison au contraire je
pense que si c'était vraiment toutes les
raisons de prouver que ce n'est pas une
question de genre c'est juste une
question de compétence
c'est mon message pour aujourd'hui et
j'espère que les autres femmes pourront
inspirer beaucoup plus merci